hi i'm michelle of Lab Muffin Beauty
Science chemistry phd and cosmetic chemist
today i'm going to be reviewing a bunch of korean
skincare products i've recently tried from brands
i haven't really reviewed much before and there's
actually some really interesting biology involved
this video is sponsored by stylekorean
an online store that stocks a lot of
korean products which i'm sure
no one expected from the name
like and subscribe and click the nerdification
bell so you know when new videos go up
the first brand i'm talking about is lagom
lagom means not too little not too much just
the right amount in swedish and that's pretty
much what this skincare brand's approach is
their products try to give skin what it needs
in the right amount and removing what it doesn't
need but not removing too much the main thing
that made me really interested in lagom is
that the people behind the brand includes
a team of 12 scientists and dermatologists
as well as one of korea's top makeup artists
which is a combination you don't often see
i think it's really cool to get this
broad range of input from a lot of
different experts i think you end up with
a much more well-rounded product that way
i really love their branding and packaging as
well their scale logo is really cute maybe i
like it because it's pretty similar to my website
branding i've tried a couple of lagom products
before i've reviewed them on my blog and i really
like the formulations but they just didn't really
fit into my routine the cellup gel to water
cleanser is a really gentle morning cleanser but
i don't really need a morning cleanser their
sunscreen has a really nice formulation but
the uva protection was a bit too low
for me it's got pa with three pluses
and i just really need uva protection so i
was pretty excited to try these formulations
and i wasn't disappointed the first one i'm going
to talk about is the cellus deep moisture cream
this is one of the nicest moisturisers i've
ever used i'm not sure if i can say favorite
yet but it is definitely up there it's really
lightweight and hydrating you don't need to use
a lot it absorbs really nicely it has a silky
texture it works really well under makeup which
i guess is not surprising given that a makeup
artist had input i'm actually wearing it now
i mixed it in with my foundation it also works
really well to hydrate your skin overnight and
it's one of those moisturisers where your skin
is still hydrated in the morning and surprisingly
it was still hydrated after washing with cleanser
i have pretty dehydration-prone skin so finding
something that gives me that dewyness without
being too much or too heavy because i'm also oily
is amazing this cream gets my skin to that perfect
amount of dewyness where it's not gross and shiny
but it's just really hydrated getting your skin
well hydrated is a really good way of hiding pores
and texture if you plump up your skin then pores
and fine lines look a lot less obvious that's what
you really want if you're going for glowy skin
you want smoother texture and hydration is one
of those things that seems temporary but makes
a massive difference if your skin is dehydration
prone and you want something that really packs
a punch without being too heavy or greasy
this is so good it is fragranced but it's not
too strong and the smell goes away really quickly
it smells a bit like lemon lollies it has been
clinically tested to be really non-irritating so
it should be fine for sensitive skin
unless you're really unlucky in terms
of ingredients it's got lots of humectants and
light emollients and an active called Aqualicia
Aqualicia is listed as hydrolysed vegetable
protein in the ingredients list it's actually
an acacia seed extract mixed with maltodextrin
and this works on aquaporins you might have heard
skincare companies talking about nobel prize
winning science and basically what this is is
the nobel prize in chemistry in 2003 was given to
two scientists that worked on discovering channels
in cell membranes the cell membrane is like the
outside of a cell the barrier it's sort of like
the skin of a cell if we zoom in it looks like
this so for a substance to get into a cell it can
either diffuse through the cell membrane which
is quite tricky some molecules can do it some
molecules can't and you can't really do much to
help that the other option is if it fits into one
of these special channels it has a much easier
time going in it's sort of like a vip entrance
there are tons of different channels and one
type is for water and these are called aquaporins
because they're sort of like a special pore for
water now the top layer of your skin the stratum
corneum or what we usually call the barrier this
acts a lot like a cell membrane much like a cell
membrane there are aquaporin channels in it and it
turns out a lot of ingredients that interact with
these aquaporins are really effective at hydrating
deep in your skin for example one of my favorite
ingredients glycerin my precious is one of the
few molecules that some of these channels let
through along with water and it's probably one of
the reasons why glycerin is just so darn good at
a hydrating skin it also turns out that tons of
ingredients that we already use in our skincare
products seem to do stuff with aquaporins and some
of them aren't really well known for moisturising
so for example caffeine and retinoids are really
good at acting on aquaporins and we all know that
retinoids do not hydrate your skin so i don't
think it's really worth specifically seeking out
aquaporin products if you want to help hydrate
your skin it doesn't really tell you more about
whether the product will hydrate your skin than
reading reviews or trying it out on your skin
this ingredient has been specifically tested
for hydration and it works really well
it is also a humectant so it could also
be that long story short whether it's
the Aqualicia or the rest of the
ingredients that's doing the work
this is an absolutely gorgeous moisturiser
that hydrates my skin so much better than
a lot of other products i've tried so i
think it's probably the combination of both
the next lagom product i tried
was the cellus aqualene solution
this is an anti-aging and hydrating essence it's
a newer launch from lagom it's only been out for
less than six months and it is very hydrating
i would say it is kind of violently hydrating
it has a really unusual texture that i quite like
it's very thin and it feels like an oil it spreads
really easily and after it's been absorbed
it's not oily it's probably the product with
the most dewiness packed into each drop i've ever
tried on my whole face i needed like four drops
and i think it's actually a really good value
hydrating product because you need so little to
spread on your face this has a lemon fragrance it
is a bit stronger than the cream but it doesn't
become too noticeable if you mix it into another
product and you don't really need a lot of it
as well as Aqualicia it's also got aquatide
which is a really interesting anti-aging peptide
it works on texture it moisturises skin it's also
antioxidant it's gotten tons of awards and hype i
really like this it is excellent and hydrating but
i guess i'm not quite as impressed by this as i
am with the cream because there are quite a lot of
hydrating serums out there although the texture of
this is really lovely and quite unique and i think
i'll be using this a lot more going into winter
the next i tried is atopalm and i was
really excited to try these because atopalm
and their parent company neopharm they're really
famous for doing a bunch of peer-reviewed studies
on skin care they're particularly well known
for studies on moisturisers and the impact
of moisturising on your skin and on your body
in general if you read articles and textbooks
about the signs of moisturisers you'll just
keep coming across atopalm and neopharm
these products are MLE products and what that
stands for is multi-lamellar emulsion technology
what it means is that these products use the
right mix of three types of lipids which are
oily ingredients specifically it's cholesterol
free fatty acids and ceramides and they actually
use patented versions that they make from plant
ingredients this mix is special because it means
that the final product has a really similar
structural arrangement to the lipids that are
naturally in your skin barrier so the idea is
these products are really good at meshing with
and adding to your skin's lipids so it's adding
a barrier to your skin while being as similar to
your skin as possible there's evidence that this
is better at hydrating skin and it makes a really
good base for delivering active ingredients
the research on MLE has been around for almost
20 years so it's actually quite surreal to be
holding and using the products that i keep on
reading about so yeah i guess it's pretty obvious
that i'm probably pretty biased here because i'm
reviewing these products after seeing scientists
hype them up ever since i started getting into
the science of skin care i guess to no one's
surprise atopalm has a really good reputation as
a dermocosmetic in korea these are those products
that dermatologists recommend for sensitive skin
fun fact some of the researchers that did the
MLE research including the founder of atopalm
were involved in developing aquatide which
was the active ingredient in the lagom product
first up we have the mle cream this was the
first korean skincare product to be officially
recognised by the ministry of food and drug safety
as a functional cosmetic helpful in restoring
the skin barrier function it has the mle in it
which is the special mix of ceramides and lipids
it's also got a whole bunch of other moisturising
ingredients like shea butter hyaluronic acid amino
acids and allentown this is a really thick cream
with a mild eucalyptus scent it feels sort of like
you're getting a really light whiff of a medicated
ointment it's targeted for dry and sensitive skin
so it's thicker and more emollient than a lot of
the other products i've been trying but it still
doesn't feel greasy i have oily skin and it's
coming to the middle of summer here in australia
so i haven't really been able to test this
properly on my face but i did have a flaky elbow
for a week that i just kept on ignoring because
that's just who i am eventually i remembered i
had a whole bunch of skincare and i should do
something about it so i put this on it and it
pretty much just stopped being flaky overnight
which i thought was incredibly impressive the mle
lotion is pretty much the same sort of product but
it's in a much more lightweight texture i've been
really impressed by the cream so far i'm going
to have to test it out properly in winter and
i'm going to have to try the MLE lotion on my face
in winter but so far everything looks really good
the final brand i tried is from neogen
dermalogy it feels like i'm missing a
syllable there dermaled dermology dermalogy neogen
is a brand i've seen around but i haven't really
tried them and there isn't that much info
about the brand online so i don't really have
a good idea of what the brand story is they have
some mysterious six core technologies thing and
they might have some clean beauty in there
which i think they've rebranded as conscious
the two products i tried are snail products from
their cica repair snail range snail mucus is a
classic korean skincare ingredient and at least
two og asian skincare bloggers named their blogs
after this ingredient 50 shades of snail and holy
snails it's one of the few gimmicky exotic asian
skincare ingredients that stuck around unlike
things like starfish extract and horse oil which
i'm pretty sure no one cares about anymore i think
that's decent evidence for snail extract working
for a lot of people it's good for a bunch of
things brightening hydration and smoothing
obviously snail mucus is not vegan but the snails
don't get killed in the process of harvesting
newer processes claim that snails aren't harmed on
the website in the product descriptions for these
two products neogen actually says using snail
mucus extracted in a natural way not in an abusive
or harsh way in an environment where snails can
live without stress from the outside environment
so they really make a sound like the snails are
in a day spa i'm sure it's not quite that nice but
i think it is a lot gentler than it used to be
so both products have a lot of snail mucus in
them they also have centella extract which you can
probably tell from the cica repair name the cream
also has two percent niacinamide both of these
have really gooey textures which is pretty typical
for snail products they're really hydrating and
lightweight and a little goes a long way with
these the gooey snail texture was actually a deal
breaker for me with the snail cream i found it
really hard to get a small amount out of the jar
it's also a bit liquidy so with my pathological
lack of coordination it feels like it's always
about to spill out of the jar i also just really
didn't like the scent of this product it has
this berry-ish cherry smell which i just have a
particular aversion to it's also stronger than
i like and so i couldn't really ignore it this
does seem to be reasonably good for sensitive skin
though i've seen reviews saying that they usually
break out with snail products but not with this
the snail essence is a lot more
manageable since it comes with a pump
but it does have that same scent i do really
like the packaging though it's pretty cute and
fun but i think i'm just not really the target
audience for this i think maybe i'm just too old
i think these products will work really
well for someone who wants to try some
snail products that target uneven skin tone
that are also really good at hydrating skin
so i hope this was an interesting review let me
know if you've tried any of these products before
and what you thought like and subscribe if you
like science based beauty content follow me on
instagram and tiktok and check out my blog as well
and i'll see you next time for more beauty science